[Music]
what is your most embarrassing moment
nick
man i got a lot so direct uh
how about your crocs right now i think
that's up there no i have
i have way more embarrassing moments you
got rainbow crocs which
christmas song my wife got this from me
christmas socks are you showing those
socks i mean the the the uh they can't
handle [ __ ]
i love you bro they're so comfortable
you know and the thing is it's like
i i totally want to get beat up or
something i don't know i will eventually
but
um uh she got them from me and i was
like
i'm going to wear them everywhere and i
wear them everywhere because are they
comfy
they're so comfortable i've only ever
had one pair of crocs and they were for
work when i used to work at the hospital
they were like anti-slipped or
whatever but they were so hard it was so
uncomfortable crocs are known to be soft
no
not these you had a clogs or what yeah
there were clogs dude people buy me
shoes
for some reason i get shoes a lot at
christmas time but bro
i have wide feet so i can't be [ __ ]
around
like i literally wear the most destroyed
pair of [ __ ] shoes
but they're skater shoes and they're
wide wow so they keep sending you hints
people keep giving yeah they keep on
giving me just regular those knees what
are those well you gotta get like
wide fit yeah wide fit always got to be
wide what side shoe are you
13. a bison for christmas please why
please one narrow
it's getting like high heels he knows
all the wide shoes he knows
yeah so what about embarrassing moments
like you know one of those moments i'm
sure you guys can relate
where you think someone's talking to you
and you respond to them or like
you think something's happening and then
you're like you wave coveted waves i've
done a lot of those because like
maybe somebody waved at me in a store
real quick and i because we're
all we all mask on and [ __ ] and i'd do a
wave back but then we're not waving at
me and
how many well cause i don't have glasses
so i don't know who the [ __ ] waving at
me so sometimes i'll i'll just
you're so nice because if i didn't know
i would just not look and then if they
approach me like i'm so sorry i just i
can't see
i just assume it's somebody who i know
and then yeah it's
i feel like that stuff's not that
embarrassing no it's not because it
happens
it probably happens like every day
somehow right happens to everyone
why do i feel the need to like cover up
afterward as if yeah
what did you do embarrassing the ball
man i was just cracking myself like i
feel like recently really embarrassing
moments are like when you
uh [ __ ] up on like a zoom call or
something like that like you forget
you're
not on mute and you either like you know
when you're jacking off you start
beating off like crazy
oh my god it wasn't that bad my uh my
now fiance anyways uh nina was uh she
does
um telehealth right so she's like on
calls and stuff and last time she was on
a call with like you know
a kid who's developmentally disabled and
uh
family and like her ot superior and
stuff like that and i walk out of a
meeting
from my my room and i'm just like heated
about something like what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] she's on the call she's on the
call
and obviously it's like super awkward so
like oh no doing that for yourself is
one thing doing that to like
someone else yeah that's i was like oh
no she's a medical professional right
yeah but obviously after the call
after the call she's got a follow-up
call with her like ot spirit and whatnot
and it's like hey did you hear that it's
like yeah everybody heard that like the
adults heard it but luckily the kid
probably doesn't fully
understand what's going on but still
it's just one of those like that counts
i'm so angry now i need to change
everything about my this is my living
space you know what i mean once you have
to adjust to like
the work from home environment like all
that but because i'm so stupid and i
ran you as a dancer person all i can
think about is your zoom call they're
like yo i want to debut this move
and you're like what the [ __ ] that's not
a move that was terrible
that could be your only problem that's
my only problem that's what brandon does
that's fun
what the [ __ ] is this move man come on
man
we'll never be able to pull that off
that's too crazy every zoom meeting is
like how are we going to save the rec
center guys
we got to get back to the old way of
dancing sonny sold this out what the
[ __ ] man deja vu i'm like we've already
done this
we've done the jk music don't have too
many dancers on the show then
this is going to happen that's true
because they only live one life
yeah anyway it's a land of tropes here i
have a tick tock here of this girl who
shared her her experience her most
embarrassing moment ever that was caught
on camera
oh caught on camera is different feeling
is one thing
having to feel it for the rest of your
life what's she doing pissing her pants
thinking about the time when i thought
the waiter was giving me a hug for my
birthday but he was just grabbing the
candle
oh that's hilarious though that's really
funny
waking up in the morning thinking about
so many things
i just wish things would get better
what a nice surprise for the waiter he
got a hug from somebody no but he was
celebrating and dancing and like there's
a way funnier tick tock video where
there's like a chiropractor working on a
girl in the gym and then he pushed her
and she like farts ella have you seen
that one
bear she let him post it you don't it's
like
super funny she got relaxed like her
friends are there too you know once you
got like hype men around yeah yeah
someone's like and the doctor's trying
to be a professional he's like
and everybody's like and then that gets
posted that's [ __ ] crazy
that's way worse way more embarrassing
this is sweet the trend of hot chicks
getting cracked by chiropractors that
like
no is that a thing yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
yeah and they know what they're doing
these chiropractors bro
they're trying to go viral not to be hot
and i'll still watch the chiropractor
video i don't know i just enjoy
like seeing because i like chiropractors
as myself i like the pop sound
i like it done to me but i hate the pop
sound it makes me like that that's
what's awesome
that's like people popping you know it's
hot chicks and like yoga pants and like
like all huge boobs huge titties
everywhere that's what they got to do
with
pimple popping i gotta get a bunch of
hot girls and pop pimples like i could
i could crack my own but i hate hearing
people crack their knuckles
or their back or crack things so what
they do is the doctor manipulates them
and then obviously we're supposed to be
getting off to it or something but
it's like super we're watching hot
people mm-hmm like i said though
regardless of the hot chick i'll still
watch this
the crack is a good you take somebody's
head and you're like
i'm like i love it i like it too it's so
sick
i can't i'm into it i do it all the time
i do it on the show all the [ __ ] time
i'm always cracking my [ __ ] because and
then pimple popping is even more fun
sometimes
i only know how to crack my back i go
like this and it cracks
but that's it i don't know anything else
yeah like quick cracks i think it's okay
but like a whole ass chiropractor video
oh god no
i cracked nicki's back i pick her up and
do the [ __ ] like oh i
i love hearing oh i wish casey would
know how to do that every time we try he
always [ __ ] my backpack it's really
easy how do you do this wrong
yeah i know no there is ways to do it
wrong no i know but i'm like i just wish
casey would
do it right what does he do he just
picks me up and he slams you underneath
are you timing your like you have to
surprise the back though
are you putting your hands like of the
shoulders elbow on top of the elbow
down and it's on the second breath not
the first exercise
where's he at where is he grabbing you
he he doesn't know where to grab so he's
trying to grab my elbows
you guys should watch a tutorial on it
get up get up get it look at this
can we get an example and then well
bart's [ __ ] white as [ __ ] though
and the chair is there but i usually
grab here no lower you got to get lower
this [ __ ] chair is yeah and you're
holding the wrong thing it's right here
all right so over here you got to hold
it but you got to relax elbow over elbow
and then put your chin down
center deep inhale exhale
yep one more time i'm excited to watch
this [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm excited too this
is great
on camera oh i heard something i think
he cracked
wow i love you that's me how's you for
show oh
dude i wish anthony's out of breath
right now
and i have a boner
crack the fart oh
a little bit a little bit in the front
and the in the beginning of it
when he lifted me up it already started
he's already built and
what if it's a height thing i think i
think it does that makes it happen
he's taller than me that makes it easier
but you guys are like what about the
other way
if you lay on the ground and then he
goes from the back like that yeah he
can't do it
i know how to do it because that's
easier i know and i tried teaching him
yeah
he's impossible also more dangerous i
feel like really yeah i think i'ma break
my lady's rib when i do it yeah and then
she doesn't like me doing this one oh
but i'm like that one's better i think
but i just pressed it down because you
could control the pressure and you push
down and
in there's a bunch of chiropractors
watching right now they're like you guys
are
[ __ ] up stop doing it ever dude i
can't wait for them to get on tick tock
and tell us about what we're doing wrong
with a hot chick no but like when you
guys massage
like what part of your finger or thumb
do you use this big one
this one it depends on the area of your
massage it depends though yeah yeah
right no i'm serious like i'll prefer an
elbow right now never this right
no oh cause that's what i get from my
finger with this one too hey this guy
i get the tip stupid well it depends
because he'll massage like this and i'm
like what are you doing
it's awkward you mean like here's
chinese kung fu yeah he uses
this and he sometimes uses his nails
he's trying to just make you stop moving
i don't know the funny thing is his dad
used to own a massage place
i know why where does he learn how to
yeah
i'm gonna tiny it's not like he doesn't
try because i'll tell him like
maybe please not that maybe he's [ __ ]
good
because of his dad and he's like dude if
i show her how good i am it's over for
me oh it's the next level thing because
now
every night he's like can you massage me
i'm like yo
that's like that's my only wish is that
if he
could just give a good does he finger
bang you good
yeah does he figure it good yeah does
he's
by the way not so good at cooking with
his mouth i find no he's not
he can play piano does he eat with his
hands yeah maybe that's what he's
playing piano instead of instead of like
trying to need him he can play the
guitar
is that right farts are great at
massaging like my [ __ ] is not a guitar
my body's not a piano tell us more great
things about casey
yeah okay no but yeah so that's why i'm
like okay you're able to do these
amazing artistic things
why can't you massage me perfectly
massage no not even perfectly
yeah like more than average she was like
don't massage me just eat me out right
now [ __ ] it that's it
at least you get a mouth massage i don't
know yeah massage is a funny thing
because there is like there's some
people innately go can you
give massage and like the even the
rhythm is off i should come up a little
bit
like i've seen he was going i'll get a
massage i'm just like
and you're just like what the [ __ ] it's
like you're just slapping like
something's like slower you're like
needing
yeah you know but there's people that
just
did that feel good
it's like a flow of a conversation right
you can't just get into it with like the
big me you got to like
warm it up he's not a jackhammering kind
of guy yeah they just pull you in the
lap and jackhammer away yeah that's not
good that's not funny
and then like i'm done no slow i
finished yeah you can't start with jack
was it as good for you as it was for me
hey you like to be porn [ __ ] right
yeah perfect me too those people are in
cells right would you say they're in
cells is that closely related no because
they're [ __ ] chills
but like when the off chance that they
do [ __ ] the first time that they do [ __ ]
or however
it's usually a jackhammer i'm sure
because in their brain they're like this
is what girls there's some impression of
porn that they've seen
yeah because that's all they know
okay variation of rhythm is important
progressive
yeah like eyes closed okay
i could watch those chiropractor videos
all day though i really could